I I want to talk about Antarctica
because I think this is going to be the
new obsession I feel like it's trending
super high who knows if there's any
truth to it but a friend of ours who
will remain nameless went there yeah
got to call it a cool experience trip
Etc and he said a couple interesting
things he said the mountains looked
eerily pointy and four-sided
uh uh he said way more mountainous than
he thought it would be I think the
illusion made from looking at maps and
watching Penguins
you can see mountains on the orontius
Phineas map version oh is that what the
little edges around the edges there
interesting those are mountains now he
also said this he's a couple things he
said there is a pact with every country
that has a slice of it that they will
not dig or remove any minerals from
Antarctica and he even said that a
scientist was there said to them world
war three will not start until one of
these countries breaks that pact they
are clearly protecting or preserving
something that may or may not be under I
believe it's three miles Mark was saying
earlier at its thickest of ice now
Mark maybe you should describe the thing
that you were saying before about there
was a time where yeah reading an article
that perhaps 90 million years ago there
was a lush rainforest that is now
covered in miles of ice on the Antarctic
continent yeah that's probably true if
you go if you go back that far
uh you would find that um the earth's
climate was very different from from how
it is today and there's no there's
undoubtedly a time they found fossils on
Antarctica there's undoubtedly a time
when when Antarctica was was Lush and
green the question is was it Lush and
green during the lifetime of the human
species yes this is where it gets tricky
and this is where this is where it gets
tricky uh our the the the the the homo
sapiens line descends from a line that
goes back about six million years not
much further than that if we accept
conventional evolutionary theory so six
million years ago Antarctica is supposed
to have been as cold and Frozen as it is
today now when I wrote Fingerprints of
the Gods in 1995 which is which is my
first book Tracing the possibility of A
Lost Civilization I was very interested
in Antarctica and I was interested in it
because of the work of a previous
researcher called Charles hapgood
Charles Hopkins wrote a number of very
important books one of them is called
maps of the ancient sea Kings which
precisely goes into this issue of
ancient maps that don't fit our
understanding of what the world was how
the world was supposed to be known at
that time and another is called the path
of the pole and he proposed a phenomenon
that he called Earth crust displacement
whereby from time to time the entire
outer crust of the earth like the skin
of an orange might shift leaving the
core of the Earth in place that it could
like so if you imagine a very loose
orange skin the fruit is inside it's
staying in place but you're Shifting the
skin around it well obviously then if
that happens it could have been in
warmer latitudes and could have been
shifted into colder latitude and how
often does this happen well does it
happen at all is the first is the first
question I mean of of all the theories
I've looked at and supported this is
this is the one that I've come in for
the for the most criticism for
um and I've been much more interested
recently in the younger driest impact
hypothesis and the notion that the the
cataclysm occurred around twelve
thousand eight hundred years ago caused
by impacts of comet fragments and we can
go into that but when I wrote
Fingerprints of the Gods although I was
interested in comets I was more
interested in Earth crust displacement
um and and the the standard academic
response to that is look Antarctica has
been frozen for millions of years
um and that rules out the whole Earth
crust displacement argument
um I think that even those who are still
researching this field would prefer it
to be the mantle rather than the crust
of the Earth that moves again it's very
technical that moves in one piece
um there's a but the idea is the Italian
Admiral called Flavia of barbiero who
who wrote an article from my website
suggesting that Earth crust displacement
could be kicked off by a comet impact
which hits the earth a glancing blow and
and causes a shift of this kind taking
place but by and large I don't I don't
argue these days that uh that Antarctica
and Earth crust displacement are the
mechanism we should be looking at I'm
more I'm much more interested in the
very solidly scientifically grounded
younger driest impact back to what back
in 1995 when I wrote Fingerprints of the
Gods I was searching around for many
possibilities that could have caused a
global cataclysm in the range of 12 to
13 000 years ago because that's what all
the astronomy pointed at 12 to 13 000
years ago and hapgood's Theory uh seemed
to me a very valuable and useful one I
still won't write it off I won't dismiss
it entirely but I've shifted in the
direction of um the younger driest
impact hypothes is simply because I'm in
a constant argument with mainstream
Academia and the issue to me the most
important issue to me is the issue of a
global cataclysm at the end of the Ice
Age what what caused that cataclysm is a
secondary issue the cataclysm itself is
the primary issue and I found the
younger driest impact hypothesis a
better much more scientifically grounded
explanation for that cataclysm uh than
the notion of Earth crust displacement
but do any archaeologists or any of
these uh prehistorians dispute the
younger dress
there's still a lot of argument around
it there's about 60 major scientists
um who are involved in the comet
research group they're all credentialed
scientists they've all published dozens
of papers in peer-reviewed journals
including nature including scientific
reports and many many others on the on
the hypothesis but there's also a group
of academics who are opposed to it and
and uh dispute that any impact ever took
place and then even in those who who do
accept that the younger dryas was a
cataclysm some think that it may have
been caused by solar activity rather
than by by comet impact how would that
work well it would certainly it could
work
um at the end of the younger dryers
there are two moments in the younger
dries the beginning is twelve thousand
eight hundred years ago it's a very
strange moment in Earth history this is
when
um this is this is when the world's
climate which has been warming up for a
few thousand years the ice age is still
very much present have big ice caps on
North America big ice caps on Northern
Europe
um but it's been warming up gradually
and then 12 800 years ago two things
happened at once first a sudden
cataclysmic drop in climate the cold it
gets incredibly cold uh as cold as it
was at the peak of the Ice Age more than
20 000 years ago it gets incredibly cold
but then puzzlingly there's a release of
water into the world ocean I say
puzzlingly because when the earth is
freezing you would not expect melt water
to be going into the world ocean it
should be staying on the ice caps and I
cite the work of cesari Miliani and his
work on the submergence of Bohemian
corals this is how do you know that sea
level Rose there are certain corals that
could only exist within a certain number
of feet of the of the sea surface so
they need the sunlight yeah and when
they drown yeah that tells you the sea
level has risen and they point to a
significance sea level rise twelve
thousand eight hundred years ago at
exactly the moment of this deep freeze
the comet impact hypothesis explains
that because it says that the shock at
the heat of the impact of large
fragments of a comet on the North
American and European ice caps would
have been sufficient to release that
freezing water into the world ocean to
cut the Gulf Stream that's the central
heating system of our planet it's called
the global meridianal overturning
circulation it's these currents of warm
and cold water that flow around the
planet and they the Gulf Stream was cut
and the Earth got extremely cold so I
think the comet impact hypothesis does
best explain that but so just real quick
so comet hits yeah cuts the Gulf Stream
cutting the Gulf Stream across the Gulf
Stream because it releases a huge
quantity of melt water from the North
American ice cap almost instantaneously
so the comet hits the ice yeah that is
in North America and Europe and Europe
that water cuts the Gulf Stream because
it releases all this which was frozen
freezing water gotcha goes into the
world ocean temperature plummets
temperature plummets but at the same
time there's much more potential water
in the oceans so that when the
temperature does rise now you have that
melt water well no so no now we need to
go on 12 800 years ago in the Thousand
or 1 200 years after that that's a
window when all the great Ice Age
megaphone are go extinct
saber-toothed tiger woolly mammoths
mastodons giant sloths the whole
collection of of famous Ice Age
megaphone they all go extinct in that
window
um and and clearly they didn't go
extinct for no reason there's the
cataclysm of the younger dryas that made
the mixture have you seen the oh God
what is the gentleman's name he's a guy
who I believe like excavates up in
Alaska for gold
pretty sure it is I'm forgetting what it
is right now but um
they're like images of woolly mammoths
who have been had like their legs
completely shattered but they're intact
yeah and is this a Boneyard that's been
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
right that that's that's very very very
very interesting I've not been there
I've not looked into it yet so I can't
speak authoritatively about it but it
might speak to your opinion right there
what I can't say is that's at ceradia De
lindosa in Colombia there is an eight
kilometer long rock art panel dated to
12 800 years ago which shows these
megaphone it shows it shows many of the
extinct megafauna from that from that
from that period
um to get back to the point uh so we
have this window of about 1200 years
where the Earth is very cold the
megafauna go extinct but then 11 600
years ago just as fast and dramatically
as the Earth went cold the earth goes
warm you're looking at a 10 degree rise
in global temperatures in in a couple
hundred years it goes a very very in
geological terms very rapid and very
fast and sea level rises very quickly
and what is it called 11 600 years ago
it's it's called melt water pulse 1B
there's another collapse of the ice
sheets and huge amounts of water go into
the world ocean now that that could
realistically be caused by a sudden
burst of solar activity which melted
down those ice sheets but that's not
what I go with I I still prefer the
notion that we're dealing with multiple
bombardments from Comet fragments and in
this case you're looking at a comet
fragment that goes into a world ocean uh
that sends up a huge amount of water
vapor into the upper atmosphere creates
a greenhouse effect and accounts for the
warming that takes place at that time so
two comets one that cooled things down
and when they heated things up yeah yeah
any idea why one would cool down and one
would heat up uh depends where the
impact is if the impact's on an ice cap
and it's releasing enormous amounts of
mountain water into the world ocean
you've got to make the world very cold
if the impacts in a world ocean and it's
putting a huge amount of water vapor
into the upper atmosphere it's a
greenhouse effect and the world is going
to get warmer it's all Theory it's not
fat all what is fact is the sudden
warming at the end of the younger driest
of the sudden freezing at the beginning
of the year control so we're searching
for explanations for that we're
searching for explanations I've picked
the one I I back but uh I'm not claiming
that I have to be right it's that what I
do think is really important is
recognizing this was a global cataclysm
it was sustained it wasn't just a minute
it went on for a thousand years plus and
it's in our back yard it's in very
relatively recent human history we're
almost at the edge of history when we go
to 11 600 years ago that's weirdly the
date that got Beckley Tempi in Turkey is
built 11 600 years ago that weirdly is
the date that Plato's Timaeus and
kritius gives for the submergence of
Atlantis eleven thousand six hundred
years ago before our time so what's
happening to humanity in this 1200 year
window I need to be I need to be clear
about that yeah yeah
um okay because the archaeologists roll
their eyes at any mention of Atlantis if
you even say the word Atlantis or
automatically regarded as a member of
The Lunatic friend okay uh and and if
you've even said that word all your work
all the 30 years of work you've done the
Thousand Dives that you've done on
Continental shelves all around the world
all of those can be written off simply
because you said the word Atlanta it's
it's flatter for archaeologists